ich bin ohne scheiß er licht immer das
gleiche das so gesagt eigentlich ist das
mega geil wenn man abends mal so
irgendwo hingehen kann man das ja auch
so komplett sich so klein
willkommen beim ein video ich habe heute
diesen spaß dabei den ich mal schnell
einwände und zwar ist das der technik
vielleicht kennt auch der eine oder
andere von euch und wir haben uns
gedacht kommen machen wir doch einfach
mal von videos dinge die mädchen
vielleicht besser nicht tragen sollten
das ist nur unsere meinung muss
natürlich keine antreten das wollte ich
jetzt noch mal klarstellen also jedem
das seine aber kann euch versichern der
ein oder andere junge denke ich dabei so
hv nicht den 2 teil hiervon finden die
entweder und in der video beschreibung
oder nach dem video verlinkt aber checkt
auf jeden fall erstmal dieses video ab
und an greift bei dem vor wald und wenn
euch dieses thema gefällt euch generell
das video gefällt dann würde ich mich
natürlich sehr freuen wenn er einfach
den daumen nach oben da das dann weiß
ich bescheid viel spaß ist wir wollen
gar nicht eingeladen und ich würde sagen
oder wir würden sagen wir fangen direkt
behandelt und ist ja natürlich auch mein
kanal deswegen wieso sollte ich bin mit
dem ersten punkt anfang lassen ich habe
natürlich an und zwar ich muss ganz
ehrlich bei dem ersten punkt sagt ich
finde es eigentlich ziemlich geil aber
man kann's auch übertreiben und zwar
könnt ihr doch bestimmt diese mädchen
die immer wirklich immer gleich rum
laufen das ist das so ganz standard so
leggins bis über den bauchnabel dann so
ein stück frei baufreiheit auf wenn es
eigentlich schon was anderes freies und
dann kommt hier so einen job oder wie
man das nennt und nach unten die
lieblings hochgekrempelt um diese airmax
anzuziehen ich bin ohne scheiß er licht
immer das gleiche das so gesagt
eigentlich ist das mega geil wenn man
abends mal so irgendwo hingeht kann man
das ja auch so komplett sich so klein
aber es gibt ja auch mädchen die gehen
so überall in die schule zum
vorstellungsgespräch zum arzt ja das ist
dann nicht immer ganz so weit will ich
jetzt sagen aber was ich dazu auch sagen
muss wenn ihr als mädchen wirklich so
abends mal weggeht oder so das ist ohne
witz so ich finde es traurig aber man
wird automatisch so als objekt mehr
gesehen und nicht als mensch das klingt
vielleicht aber ist so durchschlagend
seien gute figur haben das ist natürlich
ein a und o für ein mädchen hat versucht
man auf jeden fall will dass sie gar
nicht sagen und so was ist schon manche
mädchen die schlank sein wollen und
nicht den körper haben den sie haben
wollen sollten dazu stehen es gibt
abermals mädchen dies nicht tun und dann
sowas machen was echt
so dicke bauch weg hose das ist auf
jeden fall so eine rose die bei über den
bau fast zieht glaube ich und das
überschüssige fett darin zu verstecken
um die edel figur zu haben so jetzt gibt
es zwei probleme erstens was macht dir
am strand nehmt ihr dann
frischhaltefolie und winde durch zu-
oder was ist wenn ein junger da draußen
das mädchen abgestellt habe mit der
bauweise und die dann gratis beim aktien
sich fast zu entkleiden und dann
plötzlich nimmt sie die hose runter dann
kommen wir was wollt ihr damit machen
der junge wird erstmal der koffer aber
manche ist es nicht so schlimm aber er
versteht was ich meine warum will man
das überschüssige fett weg macht wenn zu
ist dann ist es so wie trainiert man uns
wegzukriegen aber man muss nicht eine
bauwerk ozawas ist irgendwas kilometer
kann dabei auch bei großen nächster
punkt ist auch mega witzig eigentlich
und zwar es ist jetzt mehr fällt das
immer mehr auf so diese 13 14 jährigen
jungs die sind jetzt auf diesen black
fischen krebsen und t shirts so guckt so
unter dem pulli her so diese schwarz mx
blabla ihr wisst genau was ich meine
ich kann irgendwie alle nicht ernst und
wenn ich irgendwie doch weil der schule
um genau so groß ist und aussieht wie 9
und dann hier t shirt an hat darunter
noch ein t shirt anderen t shirt und
noch ein t shirt gut aber das überträgt
sich dann natürlich auch noch auf die
mädchen die dann auch zum teil 1314 sind
und da ist das dann irgendwie noch
schlimmer ihr kennt doch bestimmt alle
diese leute die so übel ist diese black
fashion so installieren biografie oder
blackberry ich mache jetzt auch was
dafür kommt man schnell hier so ein
black fashion or if your life black flag
auf jeden fall haben dann auch mädchen
so die kleinen sich genauso die sehen
dann zwar aus wie junge aber gut black
fashion wenn ich ein lustiges bild
findet dann bleibe ich das mal ein so
was ist was ich damit meine so etwa
seine jungs da draußen die hot pants
sind geil dazu wissen wir nicht diese
highways oder die dinge auch heißen die
man bis zu den nippel zieht ja okay ich
will nicht übertreiben aber man sieht
sie dementsprechend ganz schön weit hoch
wie man merkt ihr es jetzt sicherlich
einfacher geht mit dem bist du
eigentlich behindert das sind voll geil
hallo aber ich weiß nicht ob es schon
jedem aufgefallen
der arsch geht davon beck es wird
einfach eine flache masse ich weiß
wirklich nicht was die bringen also in
guten arch hat man dann nicht so
finde ich ja okay jetzt gibt es ungefähr
drei oder vier menschen auf die drei
oder vier menschen auf dieser welt diese
tragen können aber wirklich dass wenn
man sie trägt wo man sagt der architekt
warum ja und warum kann man sich hier
einfach eine ganz normale fans anziehen
dann bringt nichts und geht nicht so gut
wie heute das was erst noch mit diesem
video falls euch gefallen hat es auf
jeden fall noch nach oben da für mich
selbst waren schreibt eure meinung zu
dem ganzen und in die kommentare zur
teams video kommt jetzt unten in der
video beschreibung oder hier auch
vielleicht verlinken schenkt das auf
jeden fall ab abonniert immer auch
wirklich sehr freuen
hier oben ist soll das video von ihm
verlinkt mal hin zu geben uns nicht fit
waren es einmal könnt ihr gerne
vorbeischauen und viel spaß mit dem
zweiten teil
ja das war wieder ein bisschen verplant
man gut